for more than two decades china's
economy has been the dependable engine
for global economic growth
but that engine is starting to splutter
the world's second largest economy is
slowing and president xi jinping's zero
tolerance covid19 campaign is being
blamed 30 months after it began
but in wuhan last month he signaled that
it was a price worth paying given the
low vaccination rate no country in the
world has been able to get it down to
zero so how is china going to be able to
do that particularly with its low
vaccination rates it seems a very tall
order earlier this year business
activity in shanghai was brought to a
standstill for weeks creating chaos and
food shortages now the business and
logistics hub is struggling to contain
another outbreak with households advised
to stock up on two weeks of food and
medicine while many countries are trying
to live with covert 19 along with its
multiple sub-variants china it seems
will not be joining that list anytime
soon and so for now the economy remains
stuck in a stop-start pattern this week
the government has released another
batch of economic and trade statistics
but they don't necessarily reflect
what's really happening to the economy
says one skeptical analyst
i think it's a as a reference as a
reference but uh
like all official statistics uh we
analysts uh
um
taught how try to figure how to
correctly interpret that i think that's
the key
the figure that does matter though is
the one for annual economic growth that
this year china's leaders set at 5.5
percent
i think that's going to be very hard to
achieve because there are so many
headwinds
at the moment we have inflation taking
off around the world maybe the world
economy might sink into recession so
that means
china's export markets could well
collapse
with millions of people confined to
their homes consumer confidence is flat
that's why inflation's hovering at
around two and a half percent low
compared to the us and europe
the uncertain economic path is unfolding
in a politically sensitive year
after the 20th party congress in
november president xi expects to secure
an historic third term
adrian brown al jazeera hong kong